people love the internet to Retro
wrecking tour here just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell it is
Zelda official trailer number three
launch day release day anyway it's
happening right here right now people
are freaking out online I have not
watched the trailer yet just seeing a
lot of social media reaction headphones
on very important step there
okay here we go more sky islands yep yep
that's where we're starting okay
oh my goodness that is
love that music
so the construct is fighting The Chew
jelly
oh that one's chopping down a tree
oh man I'm getting chills from this
music right now dude
yes
[Music]
okay this already looks better than the
gameplay like the quality of the
graphics and everything
another shot I think those are shrines
man
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
okay we've seen that but then the hand
was turning like a red and red and black
right there
whoa
[Music]
oh my gosh there's so much new stuff
wait who is that
[Music]
I feel like we're supposed to know who
that was
Zelda
we rely on your night and that legendary
sword he carries
our last line of defense will be link
who's that speaking
that had to be the King right
Zelda looks so different right there
when is that taking place man who is
that beside link
who was that beside him
[Music]
oh my goodness
yo that was epic right there
[Music]
all this vehicle combat
what I
[Music]
oh there's a tear right there
something only I can do dude does she
get sent back in time
and the birth of his new world
oh no way
there he is
Ganondorf
alone oh that is cool
they're gonna be fighting alongside us
you are our final hope
what's it called the glias
confirmed returning oh my gosh
wow wow
is that it hold on I'm kind of like are
they gonna drop something right there
link find me
oh dude there's some there's time travel
going on here right
I think there's time travel going on man
I think she is sent back in time okay
wow so much to process right there I
can't even think right now that by far
the best trailer we have seen so far and
I personally think the best look at
Zelda yet I mean everything I feel like
they've been kind of spoon feeding us so
far that was just an absolute
onslaught of new stuff new information
epic scenes epic moments I mean I guess
to get you hyped right before launch and
well it succeeded what do you guys think
let me know below as always thank you
all so much for watching talk to you
again soon